foreign
Alabama if you could recommend one thing
to declutter to start your minimalism
Journey what would it be it's not a
thing it's a question we started our
last Netflix documentary with this
question how might your life be better
with less now why do you ask that
question because
understanding the benefits of
simplifying is so much more powerful
than understanding the howl to it's why
I've become allergic to prescriptions
over the years because yes I can show
you how to declutter your closet but
if I do that and you don't know why
you're doing it then your closet will be
re-cluttered a week from now a month
from now a year from now and you'll
still feel that Pang of discontent so
Letting Go has so much more to do with
the benefits of letting go because those
benefits are different for everyone it's
not one size fits all when I first
started simplifying it was to regain
control of my time of my relationships
of my calendar of my finances what are
those benefits for you how might your
life be better with less and I first
heard that question from our good friend
Joshua Becker he asked that question
back in 2009 when I was simplifying my
life and he had just started this blog
becoming minimalist
and.com and
I never thought about that for I knew
that I felt less stressed or a little
bit calmer but I never really thought
about what the benefits of simplifying
might be and as soon as I understood the
benefits the how-to just took care of
itself yeah it's important to get that
context like you have to have a good
context going into it so yeah that's a
great recommendation get a clear context
and once you have that yes the the how
to will kind of unfold speaking of
context uh you know Romeo and Juliet was
written as satire like that was
Shakespeare's context for Romeo and
Juliet it was about these two teenagers
you know puppy love like just being
ridiculous with with overcome with
emotions and it's funny how we've turned
that play into like this beautiful like
amazing story and how romantic it was
but like it was actually like a it was a
satirical context when he when he wrote
that it wasn't as serious as we treated
exactly yeah and I I what a beautiful
metaphor for letting go yeah because we
take our things so seriously we hold on
to all of this stuff it's so serious I
couldn't possibly live without it
although as soon as you say that out
loud you pull that old shirt you haven't
worn in two years out of your closet and
tell yourself I can't live without this
shirt I can't be happy without this
shirt I can't be myself without this
shirt yeah you feel those things in your
heart and in your head but as soon as
you say it out loud the absurdity of
that helps you not take it as seriously
it helps you stop clinging and when you
stop clinging that is how you let go and
sometimes we we take stuff too seriously
in the form of religiously letting it go
and then turning around and imposing
that religion of minimalism onto other
people because we feel so righteous
about the small number of things that we
have right but how do you know if
something is clutter you only know if
it's clutter by the fact that it gets in
the way it gets in the way of your piece
gets in the way of your freedom gets in
the way of your joy gets in the way of
the things that you want to fill your
life up with and so you can never know
if something is clutter for someone else
unless you are in tune with that someone
else's why and that's why you always
have to start with that question right
what is getting in the way of me living
the life that I want to live and then
once you identify that you can go beyond
I gotta get rid of that this or I gotta
make them get rid of that and you can
just say okay the pieces fit together
this gets in the way of the life that I
want this gets in the way this can stay
because it actually makes me feel good
this can stay because it's a useful tool
and you're not even counting things
anymore but you're focusing on the
quality of life not the quantity of
stuff
our friend Beulah was over at my house
yesterday you know Viola because she
helped design the studio and I I have
some shelves in our home and we had
accumulated a few things since we moved
in so we had some stuff from the past we
had some things from the present and I
realized that oh we're at a stage where
we now have too many things we had the
right number of things from before but
some of the things that fit my past life
don't fit into my current life and so I
needed to let go and then the question
became what do I need to let go of how
might my life be better with less is how
I start but now I know that how my life
would be better with less what would
make the space calmer what would make it
breathe better be more freeing it's not
about getting rid of everything earlier
we talked about starting with a clean
slate and I did do that but eventually
you've piled enough things onto that
clean slate that you have to start
cleaning it off again decluttering is
not a end game it's not a well I've
decluttered and now I'm set for life
it's constantly questioning the things
that you bring into your life and then
constantly question the things I'm still
holding on to and so there was a vase I
didn't anymore there was a little clock
I didn't need any more there was this
other little decorative item that I
didn't need anymore it's not those
things are bad or wrong or I should have
ever owned them they no longer serve
their purpose they're no longer adding
value to our lives and in the moment I
felt that twinge oh maybe I should hold
on to this just in case and that is a
sign that I need to let go did you enjoy
this Standalone patreon highlight if so
you can listen to full episodes of the
minimalists private podcast available
exclusively on patreon visit patreon.com
the minimalists or click the link in the
description your support keeps our
podcast and YouTube Channel 100
advertisement for free